bonjour bertrand carrure un bon jour
jimmy bonjour à tout le monde et bonjour
à fred michel tyro bonjour monsieur
caruge bonjour aux auditeurs de
martinique la première vous êtes
président de la fédération les
républicains de martinique et puis aussi
président du comité de soutien à valérie
pécresse pour l'élection présidentielle
qui approche voilà moins de trois
semaines maintenant alors la campagne
électorale ici en martinique pour
valérie pécresse a on le sait a débuté
sur fond de dissensions entre vous et
une partie des militants il y avait là
même semblait y avoir à un moment deux
structures alors vous nous direz si
elles sont concurrentes ou
complémentaires pour mener cette
campagne plutôt difficile d'ailleurs
pour la candidate alors où en êtes vous
actuellement dans l'organisation
difficile pour un candidat ou savait que
la campagne un peu partout en martinique
et dans l'hexagone est un peu atone peu
un peu peu triste elle n'est pas aussi
dynamique que les années précédentes en
ce qui concerne les comités locaux en
arctique oui à du comité pourquoi pas ça
veut dire que la candidate valérie
pécresse attire il ya du comité mais un
comité officiel que j'ai l'honneur de
présider tout simplement parce que dans
toute la france et y compris en
martinique le comité de soutien de
valérie pécresse et présidé soit par an
un parlementaire soit par la mer
et l'air et je suis le seul maire et les
seins de martinique donc c'était tout à
fait légitime et normal que madame
valérie pécresse et son staff de
campagne me sollicitent vous l'avez
d'ailleurs noté j'étais le seul élu à
parrainer valérie pécresse c'est la
raison pour laquelle finalement elle m'a
elle m'avait sollicité parce que je suis
vous y voyez mon signe vous que vous
soyez le seul élu avoir parrainé non
parce que la salle d'atur de valérie
pécresse en martinique on n'avait pas pu
convaincre d'autres territoriaux peu
partout
mais ressent forcément qu'ils soient
adhérents et l'air un peu partout dans
l'hexagone vous a pas échappé que les
élus au moins parrainer que la fois
d'avant tout simplement parce que les
parrainages son public cette fois ci on
sait qu'ils parrainent qui est à cause
de cette publicité certains ont hésité
ne pas vouloir afficher leur opinion ce
n'est pas simple même pour certains élus
notamment des maires qui ont un conseil
municipal avec plusieurs tendances
d'affiché qu'ils sont pour tel ou tel
candidat c'était également un acte de
courage donc si la raison pour laquelle
très peu de personnes ont parrainé
les candidats il ne vous a pas échappé
non plus que certains d'ailleurs n'ont
même pas eu leur parrainage très tôt on
va en revenir au fond un des du
programme des propositions de valérie
pécresse pour l'outre-mer et comment ça
peut se décliner ici mais quand même sur
le début de cette campagne bon alors
vous dites que bon là l'existence de
deux comités eux montrent que la
candidature d'alain pécresse attire mais
elle divise là en l'occurrence
tir ou alors on va pas y passer le mot
sur cinq minutes
oui mais quand même parce que tout ça se
fait dans un contexte particulier et
alors qu'il y a eu des élections
récemment où vous êtes positionnés vous
pour être élu à la
ctn cherkaoui a girl et les
présidentielles vous me parler
d'élection eu depuis un an maintenant
arnaud dupont garcia les éditeurs je
veux parler des échanges de courriers
qu'il y a eu entre catherine conconne
notamment et une partie de vos militants
au début de la campagne estimez vous que
le choix de basculer dans cette alliance
politique la martinique ensemble ait pu
porter quelconque préjudice dans la
façon dont se déroule justement
l'organisation du soutien vers les
événements pas absolument pas vous savez
que valérie pécresse dénoncer quelqu'un
d'ouverture elle a l'habitude de
travailler avec des gens de sensibilités
différentes
je rappelle que en décembre 2021 valérie
pécresse présidente de la région ile de
france a signé un accord avec la cité m
dirigée par serge letchimy
valérie pécresse est quelqu'un qui
travaille en bonne intelligence
l'important c'est les administrés les
pentes en cd français les martiniquais
grâce à cet accord de partenariat et
bien les aviculture pourront plus
facilement avoir accès aux marchés de
l'île de france grâce à cet accord les
étudiants martic et pourront plus
facilement se déplacer entre l'hexagone
et la martinique vous voyez que même si
on n'est pas de la même sensibilité
différente eh bien les élus doivent
travailler catherine coquio peu amènes
pour valérie pécresse il ya quelques
mois qu elie bruins et le groupe olin
j'avais les mots de sipopo de faire des
commentaires qu'ils souhaitent nous nous
sommes la peau différente valérie
pécresse valérie pécresse a fait la
démonstration en tant que président de
la région ile-de-france que c'est une
femme de terrain c'est une femme au
combat et président de la république
demain eh bien elle montrera également
qu' elle est la personne qu'il faut
justement pour diriger la france parce
que justement aujourd'hui après 50
quinquennat de l'actuel président la
france est divisée on a les français les
uns contre les autres et aujourd'hui il
faut plus rassemblé que d'y vivre et 6
aimant valérie pécresse propose pour les
outre-mer et pour la martinique donc qui
est concerné une loi programme pour dix
ans expliquez-nous fred michel chiron
s'est pas seulement ça il faut pas
rentrer dans les détails sont des
sactions dans le ciel en direction des
enseignants une élection présidentielle
c'est avant tout une vision un peu un
pays
qu'attend l'imatinib sa figure de la
fiche de valérie pécresse
regardez voyez que je le lait monsieur
parvenir à l'égalité réelle nous
voterons une loi de programme de
développement sur 10 ans pour valoriser
des atouts vous me laissez faire les
réponses aussi si vous prenez les sucs
arrive alors le pouvoir d'achat comme
c'est indiqué dans ce document est la
priorité des martiniquais
et c'est pour cette raison qu'elle a
parlé d' égalité sociale économique
réelle qu'est ce qu'elle propose pour le
pouvoir d'achat notamment d'abord au
niveau national une hausse des salaires
de 10% jusqu'à 2,2 smic elle propose une
exonération des heures supplémentaires
de 3% dès 2022 médias de 26% sur ce qui
semble du kaki sur le quinquennat oui
elle propose un salaire inférieur à 2005
propose également qu' aucune retraite ne
soit et ferrieu au smic il n'est pas
normal aujourd'hui que on ait cotisé
pendant 40 ans 42 ans et que certaines
retraites soit 2 500 600 700 euros elle
propose que quand on a cotisé à plein
temps et bien on est une retraite au
moins et ferrieu au moins égale au smic
voilà une retraite minimale et cyril
allanic n'est spécifique horse ball où
nos mères elle propose quelque chose
d'important l'âge et le gel de certains
prix notamment le gel des prix du
carburant elle propose également qu'on
renégocie les tarifs certains tarifs
tarifs bancaires les opérateurs internet
et téléphonique et puis elle propose
aussi qu'on renforce la continuité
territoriale l'acte continuité
territoriale non seulement pour les
étudiants et puis il l'a t la continuité
territoriale aussi pour les familles qui
accompagnent les malades qui vont se
faire soigner dans l'hexagone et
notamment pour qu'il soit hébergé plus
facilement donc il ya tout un dispositif
qu'on ne peut pas d'italie en quelques
minutes mais qui
objectif justement de
renforcer le pouvoir d'achat des
martiniquais il ya quelque chose de
particulier qu'elle propose qui
intéressera tous les martiniquais
c'est la baisse des droits de succession
aujourd'hui elle propose que
95% des familles soient exonérés de
droits de succession c'est à dire que
vous laissez une maison davud d'environ
200000 euros aujourd'hui les enfants et
les habitués doivent payer 30 40 mille
euros
elle dit que ce n'est pas normal que
vous y travaillez toute votre vie et que
vous soyez obligé le pays des droits de
succession aussi important c'est la
seule candidate qui propose que
95% des familles soient exonérés des
droits de succession c'est à dire
jusqu'à 200 milles euros eh bien on
n'aura aucun droit de succession à payer
ça aussi ça va et pour tout la votation
spécialisation spéciale pour l'amener on
ne sait pas encore spécifiquement pour
la martinique il ya aussi des
propositions qui ont été
obtenus que nous nous avions proposé
comité de soutien parce que valérie
pécresse elle a associé les comités de
soutien à l'élaboration de son programme
ça fait plusieurs mois que nous
travaillons dessus la continuité
territoriale renfort si c'était une
demande importante que nous avions fait
qui a été
acceptée et intégré dans son programme
comme vous l'avait indiqué dans le
document que vous avez sous les yeux et
puis elle a accepté également de revoir
tout le système de l'octroi de mer
aujourd'hui l'octroi de mer tel qu'il
est organisé fait peser sur les prix
mais des prix tout à fait élevé 22
profond de plus par rapport à l'hexagone
en moyenne offerte aux souris mais font
ce procès supprimé on remet à plat ce
système de telle sorte que et bien les
prix notamment les prix deux premiers
les produits première nécessité ne
soient pas frappés de poids de mais
aussi important on revoit tout le
système et puis autre proposition
qu'elle a prévu d'intégrer aussi c'est
qu'on applique les zones de
revitalisation rurale à l'âme entier que
sont des dispositifs qui ont fait leurs
preuves dans l'hexagone ce à dire que y
en a 10 and génération de de charges
fiscales et sociales pour les
entreprises des petites entreprises et
les professions libérales
oeuvre pour favoriser le développement
économique de la martinique valérie
pécresse propose alors une création de
la banque d outre-mer ça c'est pour te
pour tous les territoires voilà et puis
aussi alors je dirais que nous en disait
quelques mots avant de conclure un une
banque nationale des jeunes pour aider
les jeunes à financer leurs projets et
leurs études tout à fait c'est à dire
que elle elle indique qu' il faut pas
donner aux jeunes nés ou moins jeunes de
l'argent sans rien faire elle estime que
le travail la responsabilité c'est le
corollaire
de l'argent et de l'aide qu'on peut
donner elle indique que elle va proposer
une banque des jeunes qui va favoriser
les projets de ces jeunes si lui un
projet de formation bien précis si l'on
projets de voyages d'études et bien ce
sera donc ses finances et fort de
service public bancaire dédié à une
catégorie de
commencer de façon étalée c'est une
banque des jeux donc j'arrive à auxerre
des prêts à tous ces honneurs et qui
seront remboursés à partir du moment où
le jeune va commencer à travailler mais
je veux insister aussi sur le point
portant sur la santé parce que c'est un
volet important de la santé dans son
programme national mais elle insiste sur
un point notamment en martinique c'est
que bien entendu augmenter le nombre de
soignants faire un grand plan hôpital
pour la martinique c'est à dire
notamment la reconstruction parce
qu'elle s'est rendu compte qu'on nous
connaît il ya un déficit de suture et
puis elle souhaite aussi que ceux qui
sont touchés par le chlordécone soit
accompagnée de la même manière qu'eux
ceux qui sont touchés par l'amiante vous
savez qu'il y à des dispositifs
spécifiques pour accompagner les
personnes touchées par l'amiante elle ne
dit qu'il n'est pas normal que l'on
n'est pas ce même dispositif pour les
personnes qui sont touchées par le
chlordécone merci fred michel terrot
pour cette première partie d'émission
donc en soutien à valérie pécresse voilà
en tête de l'un de ses prospectus la de
campagne électorale on voit une nouvelle
ambition pour la martinique et bien les
auditrices et les auditeurs et lectrices
et lecteurs en en jugeront par eux-mêmes
et elle-même
05 96 63 23 23 pour vos questions donc à
fred michel terrot vous avez la parole
sur la première